[Música]
[Aplausos]
para empezar la vía analizar dos
preguntas la primera quienes de ustedes
quieren ser felices en la vida y la
segunda es quiénes de ustedes son
felices en su trabajo
si la respuesta de la segunda pregunta
fue no no se preocupen porque según un
estudio y una investigación que realizó
gallup a nivel mundial demostraron que
solamente el 15 por ciento de las
personas son felices en su lugar de
trabajo
otro estudio realizado por la
organización mundial de la salud
demostró que el 60 por ciento de la
improductividad de los empleados se debe
al mal manejo del estrés lo cual se ha
convertido en un problema para todas las
empresas porque estos causas de
accidente de trabajo solicitudes de
capacidad
díaz por enfermedad todo esto aumenta lo
que se llama el ausentismo lo que se
traduce en grandes pérdidas para las
compañías verdad si consideramos con un
tercio aproximadamente nuestra vida la
vamos a pasar trabajando no es casual
que 450 millones de personas en el mundo
o sea estamos hablando casi del 10 por
ciento de la población mundial tengan
algún sufren algún trastorno mental o de
conducta
y que alrededor de un millón de personas
promedio se suicidan por año
para la tercera pregunta
quién de ustedes
quisiera ser más feliz en el trabajo
treinta años atrás es impensable que se
hablara de felicidad como una prioridad
en la vida y mucho menos en nuestro
laboral lo más seguro es que el tiempo
que si alguien llegaba a preguntar por
la felicidad del trabajo la respuesta
que hoy ha recibido es a causa de no
vino a ser feliz acá también a trabajar
otra frase los problemas personales
dejen su casa acá se viene a trabajar
hoy todavía queda alguna secuela de
aquel entonces pero por suerte el
entorno está cambiando
son muchos los estudios que se han hecho
en materia de felicidad y bienestar
desde el punto de vista científico
universidades de la envergadura de
harvard de pensilvania el embite y entre
otras
apostaron el estudio científico sobre la
materia de hecho un reino unido
esto se convirtió en un tema de estado
tanto así que el año 2018 se fundó el
ministerio de la soledad porque
detectaron que el 14 por ciento de las
personas estaba afectado por
enfermedades que derivan de la soledad o
sea más enfermedades que lo que produce
el consumo de tabaco
la felicidad en el día de hoy y la
creación de contextos de bienestar
hoy es una prioridad para las personas y
para las empresas ya que las cifras que
acabamos de ver y los indicadores
muestran que es una necesidad urgente y
que es un tema que tenemos que poner
encima de la mesa
me gustaría compartirles una breve
historia y para eso los invito a
trasladarnos al año 1997 imaginemos no a
un joven de 21 años aproximadamente
estudiante universitario vive con sus
padres en argentina a quien de repente
la vida
da un giro de 180 grados al enterarse
que iba a ser papá
y de pronto su vida cambió y se encontró
viajando japón con su esposa un bebé muy
pequeño y trabajando en una fábrica de
autos japonesa
las jornadas interminables 12 horas a un
ritmo agotador poner a prueba su fuerza
física mental cada día pero siempre
estaba a punto de abandonar tarea y
cuando sucedía descubrió una fuerza
extra que que es inagotable que era su
fuerza de voluntad
ese joven era yo quizás en ese momento
no entendía que me llevaba a soldar una
pizza atrás de otra y una más a pesar de
que mi cuerpo y mente ya no podía más
hoy quizás un poco más grande mirando la
retrospectiva creo haber encontrado la
respuesta
sin saberlo en aquel momento lo que me
movilizaba era un propósito
o sea no pensaba tanto en la tarea en
que así es porque realmente yo nunca el
soñado en ser un soldador en una fábrica
tampoco pensaba en los procedimientos en
el cómo lo hacía
sí y me enfocaba solamente mi propósito
final para que lo hacía y para que era
muy poderoso para que ahorrar el
suficiente dinero como para poder
comprar una casa para mi familia y
volver a mi país
luego de tres años de duro trabajo como
les conté pudimos cumplir su objetivo
volvimos a argentina y pudimos comprar
lo que fueron la primera casa
cuando le argentinas no eran muchos los
empleos a los cuales podía calificar
porque todavía no había conseguido
terminar mi facultad y mis estudios por
lo tanto me dediqué a trabajar en
gastronomía pasando por todos los
lugares que ustedes imaginan que puede
haber en un local gastronómico o en un
restorán desde lavar copas atender mesas
haciendo famoso o camareros depende del
país encargado de turno hasta llegar a
ser gerente general de toda la cadena
un cliente me conoció en el restaurante
y me ofrece sumarme a un proyecto
increíble de que estaba se trataba
realizar un lanzamiento en argentina de
una compañía de retail líder en
latinoamérica no lo dudé un segundo dije
ingresar a trabajar en esta compañía
multinacional que se dedica a la
construcción y todo lo referido al al
hogar teniendo a cargo un área de ventas
y 20 personas bajo mi dirección no
estaba súper feliz con ese desafío
siempre movilizado por el propósito
porque a pesar de no haberlo estudiado
me había dado cuenta tanto en
gastronomía como en retail que el
general excelente el lugar para trabajar
para mis equipos se traducía en
productividad la gente cuando se siente
bien piensa bien decide bien y trabaja
bien
esta compañía sucedió algo que cambió mi
carrera profesional y en mi vida de una
manera sana de trabajar en el área de
ventas christian que era en ese momento
el gerente re consumaron si es mi mentor
me ofreció ser parte de su equipo sin
dudar un momento
le dije que si fue creo que en aumentos
laborales más felices de mi carrera
porque yo encontré en área de recursos
humanos la posibilidad de impactar en
muchas más personas y poder cambiar
realidades y darles muchas oportunidades
a las personas como las que yo tuve si
ya pasaron más de 12 años de aquel
momento y sigo trabajando en recursos
humanos porque encontré en esta área lo
que en japonés se define como en que hay
que significa el sentido de la vida o el
propósito y conjuga lo siguiente lo que
sos bueno lo que el mundo necesita algo
por lo que está dispuesto a pagarte y lo
que amas o lo que te apasiona
durante este tiempo fui corriendo como
una carrera muy lineal porque para eso
fuimos educados no más títulos más
cargos más responsabilidades empieza a
cambiar de compañías para elegir
compañías cada vez más grandes hasta que
llegue a ser gerente regional de la
mayor compañía de latinoamérica y a
pesar de eso me preguntaba
recurrentemente si ese era realmente mi
propósito como todas las grandes cosas
parte de una pregunta así me planteaba
la cantidad de cosas que hacía si así
hacía para tener tener tener tener cada
vez más y yo pensaba que en función de
tener más cosas iba a lograr ser esa
persona que yo quería
hoy mi propósito ser se resignificó fue
reordenar las palabras de mi propuesto
llegar a ser primero hacer para poder
hacer lo que me apasiona y en
consecuencia tener la paz y felicidad
que todos buscamos solo cambie el orden
algunas palabras como saliendo de cuenta
estaba todo ahí todo ahí el error creo
era buscar afuera lo que solo puedes
encontrar cuando miras para adentro
hoy creo haber logrado muy muy
importante en mi carrera que es conectar
al cien por ciento con mi propósito y mi
propósito es colaborar del otro lado del
mundo laboral y acompañar como consultor
a otros líderes en el camino de
resignificar este concepto de trabajo el
concepto de trabajo como definición
viene de la palabra tortura de tripalium
que si ustedes se fijan buscan el
significado de la etimología de la
palabra trabajo strip alias the tree
palio que era un elemento de tortura de
la época medieval así nació el concepto
del trabajo
todo esto vino a cambiar vino a dar
muchos cambios y nuevos escenarios este
nuevo escenario nos impulsa nos obliga a
crear nuevas prácticas y actividades muy
discutidas y muy innovadoras con una
visión más holística a la persona si
viendo a la persona de una presión como
un ser humano no como un recurso humano
como un ser humano tridimensional
trabajar sobre la dimensión física
cognitiva y emocional de la persona
esto no va a ser fácil esto supone
construir un mecanismo de escucha
permanente si ya no alcanza con eso la
encuesta de clima que esa que hacíamos
una vez o dos veces por año tenemos que
asegurarnos de estar haciendo las
preguntas correctas a las personas
adecuadas en el momento específico y
obviamente actuar en consecuencia de eso
ya creo que el concepto de employee
spearing quedó corto ante esta nueva
normalidad se cayó el telón corporativo
y quedó al descubierto todo lo que había
detrás de esa fachada corporativa había
seres humanos incompletos imperfectos y
que no han descubierto lo mejor de las
personas lo más noble del ser humano y
de las empresas y también las miserias
más grandes
nosotros los profesionales que
trabajamos en gestión humana en gestión
de personas tenemos que desafiar todos
nuestros procesos y dejar de lado todas
estas prácticas jurídicas las cuales
abrazamos y que en definitiva y al final
del día sólo la hacen sentido el equipo
de recursos humanos si para que definir
descripciones de puestos con roles que
no tienen nada que ver con la realidad
diseñar los recursos organigramas que no
reflejan la realidad de la compañía
y comenzar a hablar de proyectos de vida
más que planes de carrera y empezar a
dejar de usar palabras tremendas como
reclutar reclutar me viene a la cabeza a
la gente que obligaba a nadie a las
guerras para empezar a hablar de
atracción de talento que la gente elija
trabajar estas compañías y dejar de
retener el talento para potenciarlo
retener me suena a alguien que está en
contra en su guild actual y que está
secuestrado
durante este tiempo nos llevó a tocar
nos llevó a llevar nuestro trabajo a
nuestras casas para poder salvar el
mundo cuando todo esto pase creo que
será el tiempo y que podamos nosotros
llevar nuestras vidas al trabajo para
salvarlos como seres humanos
en palabras de nelson mandela lo que
cuenta en la vida no es el mero hecho de
haber vivido sino son los cambios que
hemos provocado en la vida los demás lo
que después de terminar significa verde
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]